okay this is a second test recording I
don't know if it's weird if I look at
the camera but for the most part I won't
we're playing an FM this is mainly to
test video and sound quality and now
speed he's playing a bird or reverse
Dutch but he can't take my a4 pawn now
I'm playing checkers just put all the
pieces on light squares oh oh I can get
away with this
hello as a good move
come down a pond or two only one pond
but maybe that was a mistake I can take
oh okay I'm just going to trade Queens
game down upon a king g---seven like
Yasir and take
I don't mind this position even though
it's probably really bad for black
because I'm gonna put a rook on d5 at
some point and I'll still be down upon
maybe even two pawns if he takes here I
would like to play oh I wanted to play a
three now I'll activate my king and my
knight and life will be okay maybe
except he's winning another pawn okay I
have to start winning pawns but I know
that's possible
my night is so clumsy
Knight c7 maybe I'll win no I can't
let's do this in a seven yes I have some
kind of fortress here I can't take that
play ch 500 if I have two moves in a row
I made him play
I can do this and then this okay my life
kind of maybe he can still meet me
what is this position
can break through I'm breaking through
but he can take with Bishop maybe I'll
still still may me
wait I'm winning
I'm clogging him uh
Queen EA was a very bad move
what is this lag
yes I win